welcome back to drew's news i'm kiki
palmer and this next one is perfect for
beauty week okay it's all about how to
use your eyes to hypnotize the cut
reports tick tocker michelle diaz says
that the white dot makeup trick will
make people fall in love with you i mean
this is crazy guys she swears by it she
says all you got to do is take white
eyeliner and put your four dots around
each eye i mean
ross you seem like you're already
getting ready to do it hold on i'm no
dummy so you do oh okay that's a big dot
love
thank you so much for noticing okay here
we go like this right that's what she
did
i don't think
what do you think i mean
well you got messy with it
well
i thank you for it
i mean i don't know i mean i was already
in love with you a little bit i don't
know if i'm how much more look at me one
more time let me see
i mean is it anything
i don't think i did it right
yeah well you should fix my he got that
smudge can i see her picture how did she
do it so she did one at the top one at
the bottom of one of the two sides like
you did oh also like and it doesn't move
this is a heavy eyeliner when what you
have to let it you have to like um
let your eyes dry because because he
moves
like a clown
there are elements of it that look
really good
that side's really good this side okay
because it's
because the way she does it is really
subtle yeah yeah yeah
something that i developed at flower
beauty this was really important to me
um is i wanted to develop a white
mascara it's actually that's very fish
really pretty
really attractive very soft and with the
holidays coming up it's called snow
queen you can get your hashtag white
lashes on with a red lip and feels super
holiday i love the hair movement with
that made me feel really good like i i
have to tell you every time i wear it i
feel pretty i feel attractive
um so i'm really i'm like trying to
start this trend we'll see if it catches
on okay what do you think yes did it
work hi
well actually i'm like
cute pile more on rossi
i do like four layers you actually do
look really really cute though yeah i
have to say i'm pretty i'm feeling
pretty fabulous maybe i should go to a
disco tonight
how about this we've got the latest home
decor trend vogue says people are
decorating their living spaces with
disco balls
yeah we've all missed going out but it
you know it it shows right we need to
have a little fun interior designers are
domesticating the disco ball bringing it
into living rooms and dens look at this
uh drew can we get a disco ball here
please i don't know can we rock please
one day could we get a disco sammy
sullivan
can we can we get this out one day
i want to dance too
i love it i can get in
you i there you i love you rusty i love
you i love you i love you guys
[Music]
you